This is 99% invisible. 9 Roman Mars. Three years after moving to New York City, Maggie Riggly found herself on the edge of homelessness. It was 1987. She and her boyfriend at the time had been living in a warehouse in Brooklyn. But their landlord was shady, and they didn't trust him. We weren't going to stay and pay him all this money, and you know, he got kind of crazy and violent. We didn't really know where we were going to stay and pay him all this money and you know he got kind of crazy and violent. We didn't really know where we were going to go.
这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。搬到纽约市三年后，玛姬·里格利发现自己濒临无家可归。那是1987年。她和当时的男友一直住在布鲁克林的一个仓库里。但他们的房东很不靠谱，他们并不信任他。“我们不打算留下来付给他这么多钱，”你知道的，他变得有点疯狂和暴力。“我们真的不知道我们要去哪儿留下来付给他这么多钱，你知道的，他变得有点疯狂和暴力。我们真的不知道我们要去哪里。
Around that time they heard about an abandoned tenement building on the lower east side. It was owned by the city, but it had been left empty and unmentained. A friend told them a group of squatters had taken it over and started to fix it up. It was a place they could live without paying rent to a landlord. And he said there's an open space. If you want to come, it's rough. You know, you've got to go through these meetings to get in. They got to approve you. It's pain in the ass.
大约在那时，他们听说下东区有一栋废弃的公寓楼。这栋楼属于市政府，但一直空置且无人维护。一个朋友告诉他们，有一群擅自占房者接管了这栋楼并开始修缮它。这是一个他们可以不用给房东交租就能住下的地方。他说，那里有一个空房间。如果你想来，条件很艰苦。你知道的，你得通过这些会议才能搬进去。他们得批准你。这真是件麻烦事。
We were like, we need a place to go. So, Riggly and her boyfriend packed up their belongings and drove their old car from Brooklyn into Manhattan. In fact, the day that we drove here to move in our axle broke on the car just just fell apart literally. It's like right outside the front door. So it was like, okay, yeah, so we moved in. The building was a four story structure, with mostly boarded up windows.
我们当时想，我们需要一个栖身之所。于是，里格利和她的男友收拾好行李，开着他们的旧车从布鲁克林来到了曼哈顿。事实上，我们开车来搬进来的那天，车的车轴断了，可以说是彻底散架了。它就在前门外面。所以当时的情况是，好吧，那就这样吧，我们搬进去了。这栋建筑是一个四层的结构，窗户大多用木板封着。
That's producer Delaney Hall. And Maggie and her boyfriend discovered that when their friends said the building was rough, he wasn't kidding. The building was full of rubble. Some of the walls were rotten and falling down. There wasn't any running water. You got to open a hydrant with a wrench and then fill up these water buckets and carry
那是制作人德莱尼·霍尔。玛姬和她的男友发现，当他们的朋友说这栋楼条件艰苦时，他可不是在开玩笑。楼里到处都是瓦砾。有些墙壁已经腐烂坍塌。根本没有自来水。你得用扳手打开消防栓，然后把这些水桶装满，再把它们
them back into the house and it wasn't fun. And it was also winter time when Wrigley moved in. My dogs bowl would freeze, my shampoo would freeze, my, you know, everything would freeze in the house, the toilet would freeze. It was like living in a refrigerator. It wasn't just the building that was falling down. The whole lower east side, which today is filled with expensive boutiques in high-end condos, was struggling in the 1980s.
搬回屋里，这可一点也不好玩。而且里格利搬进去的时候正值冬天。我狗的碗会结冰，我的洗发水会结冰，你知道的，屋里的所有东西都会结冰，马桶也会结冰。那感觉就像住在冰箱里。不仅是建筑物在倒塌。整个下东区在20世纪80年代也陷入了困境，而如今这里到处都是昂贵的精品店和高端公寓。
It was pretty dire. I mean, it was a broken, brutal neighborhood. You sort of forget how astonishingly derelict it was. There were empty lots filled with trash and falling down buildings everywhere. In fact, Riggley's building wasn't the only property in the neighborhood that had been taken over by squatters. By the late 1980s, squatters would come to occupy more than a dozen old tenements on the lower east side.
情况相当糟糕。我的意思是，那是一个破碎而残酷的街区。你有时会忘记它是多么的荒凉破败。到处都是堆满垃圾的空地和摇摇欲坠的建筑物。事实上，里格利的这栋楼并不是该街区唯一被占领的房产。到20世纪80年代末，占房者已经占领了下东区十几栋旧公寓楼。
All the misfits in the outcasts and the people that didn't have any other place to go could come here and make a community. And these misfits and outcasts would eventually manage to do something kind of incredible. They'd resist eviction by the city for almost two decades. Holding on to many of the buildings has the neighborhood around them rapidly gentrified and as the properties grew more and more valuable and as the city tried harder and harder to kick them out. To understand why there were so many abandoned buildings in New York City in the 1980s, you need to understand how a usable building can become economically worthless.
所有不合群的人、被社会排斥的人以及无处可去的人都可以来到这里建立一个社区。而这些怪咖和边缘人最终竟然做成了一件不可思议的事。他们抵抗了市政府近二十年的驱逐潮。在周围社区迅速士绅化、房产越来越有价值、市政府千方百计想把他们赶出去的过程中，他们依然坚守着许多建筑。要理解为什么20世纪80年代纽约市有这么多废弃建筑，你需要明白一栋原本可用的建筑是如何变得在经济上一文不值的。
In the 1960s and 70s, New York City began hollowing out. The city lost many of its manufacturing jobs, and people with means started moving to the suburbs. In many neighborhoods, like the Lower East Side, property values started to slide. When landlords couldn't make a profit anymore by renting out their buildings in low income neighborhoods to low income tenants, they would start what's called milking them. This is Dr. Amy Starchesky. She's an anthropologist and an oral historian, and she's conducted dozens of interviews
在20世纪60、70年代，纽约市开始走向空心化。这座城市失去了许多制造业工作岗位，有钱人开始搬往郊区。在许多社区，比如下东区，房产价值开始下滑。当房东无法再通过把低收入社区的房屋租给低收入租户来获利时，他们就会开始所谓的“榨干”房屋。这是艾米·斯塔切斯基博士。她是一位人类学家和口述历史学家，她采访了数十人。
with the lower east side squatters, some of which you'll hear in this story. Starczeski says that when landlords quote unquote milked their buildings, they do all they could to extract maximum profit from them. So they were trying to continue to collect rents but increase their profits by not spending any money on the building. First, they would stop providing services,
与下东区占房者相关的采访，其中一些你将在本期节目中听到。斯塔切斯基说，当房东“榨干”他们的建筑时，他们会竭尽所能从中榨取最大的利润。因此，他们试图继续收租，却不愿在建筑上花一分钱，以此来增加利润。首先，他们会停止提供服务，
heat, hot water, stop making repairs. They would also stop paying taxes. The landlords would basically make a financial calculation. When the money coming in from rents wasn't enough to cover the cost of a mortgage or property taxes, some landlords would just walk away. They'd stop maintaining the building and stop paying the taxes they owed. When that happened, the city could take possession of the building. So as property values in New York City tanked, and as more and more landlords walked away from their buildings, the city ended up owning off services to some parts of the city.
暖气、热水，停止维修。他们还会停止交税。房东基本上会进行一番财务盘算。当收到的租金不足以支付按揭贷款或房产税时，一些房东就会一走了之。他们不再维护房屋，也不再缴纳拖欠的税款。这种情况发生时，市政府就可以接管该建筑。因此，随着纽约市的房产价值暴跌，越来越多的房东抛弃了他们的建筑，最终导致市政府拥有了对城市某些地区的公共服务控制权。
It was an intentional strategy. They called it planned shrinkage. So what that meant in practice was that the city. It was an intentional strategy. They called it planned shrinkage. So what that meant in practice was closing fire stations in poor neighborhoods, withdrawing services, not making repairs on public infrastructure. And so neighborhoods like the Lower East Side, like the South Bronx, ended up largely depopulated and just full of abandoned and burnt out buildings and vacant lots. All of which meant terrible housing conditions
这是一个蓄意的策略。他们称之为“计划性收缩”。所以这在实践中意味着这个城市。这是一个蓄意的策略。他们称之为“计划性收缩”。因此，这在实践中意味着关闭贫困街区的消防局，撤回服务，不对公共基础设施进行维修。因此，像下东区和南布朗克斯这样的街区，最终基本上人口流失，到处都是废弃烧毁的建筑和空地。所有这些都意味着极度恶劣的居住条件。
for the people that remained and lots of opportunities for squatters. The freedom of squatting also meant that you got people who were sort of already rolling and tumbling through American life. There were people who would kind of come loose in some way or another. Peter Spenuelo is a poet who moved into one of the lower east side squats in 1988. The building he lived in was filled with artists, punks, transients, activists, and displaced
对于留下来的人来说，这意味着极差的居住条件，同时也为擅自占房者提供了许多机会。占房的自由也意味着，你会遇到一些已经在美国生活中颠沛流离的人。总会有一些人以这样或那样的方式变得生活无着。彼得·斯佩努洛是一位诗人在1988年搬进了下东区的一处占地住所。他住的建筑里挤满了艺术家、朋克、流浪汉、激进分子和无家可归的
locals. There were also a fair number of squatters with mental health issues and addiction problems. People who weren't able to hold down regular jobs or make monthly rent payments for one reason or another. It was often hard to tell the difference between people like, is this person actually a psychotic on their own or are they just a little eccentric because they've been pissing in a bucket for five years and having a windows on their rooms in its January and New York. The squatters set about fixing up their decrepit buildings, clearing rubble, building stairs,
当地人。其中还有相当一部分占房者有心理健康问题和瘾君子问题。由于种种原因，这些人无法维持稳定的工作或按月支付房租。通常很难分清人们的情况，比如，这个人是真的精神有问题，还是只是有点古怪，因为他们已经在水桶里小便了五年，而且在纽约的1月，他们的房间连窗户都没有。占房者开始着手修缮他们破败的建筑，清理瓦砾，修建楼梯，
reinforcing walls and replacing windows. They illegally tapped into the city's electric grid and water system. Everybody worked together. Maggie Riggley again. I mean, I built this house. You know, I raised my floors, You know, I raised my floors. You know, I wired electricals. People built out their spaces in highly personalized ways.
加固墙壁并更换窗户。他们非法接入了城市的电网和供水系统。每个人都齐心协力。再次有请玛姬·里格利。我的意思是，这房子是我建的。你知道的，我铺了地板，你知道的，我铺了地板。你知道的，我接了电线。人们以高度个性化的方式打造自己的空间。
One guy's apartment was furnished with cabinets salvaged from an old Pan Am airplane. One apartment was done all in shades of purple with purple stained oak floors. They built big open spaces for art galleries and punctures. For a lot of people, it was thrilling to live in a place that allowed for so much freedom. And many of the squatters saw themselves as activists for cheap or free housing and a neighborhood that was plagued by homelessness. You saw it everywhere you went in New York City, every neighborhood.
有个家伙的公寓里摆满了从泛美老飞机上回收来的机舱柜。有一间公寓完全采用各种色调的紫色，并配有紫色着色的橡木地板。他们建造了宽敞的开放式空间，用作美术馆和朋克演出场所。对许多人来说，能住在这样一个享有如此大自由度的地方是令人兴奋的。许多占房者将自己视为争取廉价或免费住房的活动人士，因为当时这个社区正饱受无家可归问题的困扰。你在纽约市无论走到哪里，在哪个街区都能看到这种现象。
It was especially true on the lower east side in the neighborhood, you know, east of Tompkins Square and north of Tompkins Square. Spenulo and some of his friends would make brochures and go hand them out to homeless people in Tompkins Square Park. And the brochure was basically like, you don't have to live like this.
在下东区尤其是这样，你知道的，在汤普金斯广场以东和以北的社区。斯佩努洛和他的几个朋友制作了传单，去汤普金斯广场公园发给无家可归的人。传单的内容基本上就是，你们不必这样生活。
Within two or three blocks of this park, are dozens and dozens of abandoned buildings, you know, get together with your other folks who are living like you are and go take a building. From the early to mid 80s, the squatters didn't face much active resistance from the city. From time to time, city officials would come by and brick up their windows and doors. But the squatters would just smash through the bricks. I frankly thought that as long as the economy of New York remained kind of iffy or dodgy, we would be left alone.
在这个公园两三个街区内，有数十栋废弃的建筑，你知道的，和你们这些同样处境的人聚在一起，去占领一栋楼吧。从80年代初到中期，占房者并没有遭到来自市政府的太多积极抵抗。时不时地，市政府官员会顺道用砖把他们的窗户和门封起来。但占房者会直接砸穿这些砖。坦白说，我原本以为只要纽约的经济状况依然悬而未决、前途未卜，我们就会被安然留置。
You know, if the economic cycle started to go back into a cycle of investment, reinvestment in the city, I figured we were probably screwed. When the squatters took over the buildings on the lower east side, they were tapping into a long American tradition, a blame claimed to land by occupying and developing it. In 1862, the federal government was trying to encourage westward expansion and settlement, and so Congress passed the Homestead Act. It opened up millions of acres of land in the American West to settlers. If the settlers farmed the land and improved it,
你知道的，如果经济周期重新回到投资和在城市中再投资的循环，我想我们大概就完蛋了。当占房者接管下东区这些建筑时，他们实际上是在延续一项悠久的美国传统——通过占领和开发土地来宣示所有权。1862年，联邦政府试图鼓励向西扩张和定居，于是国会通过了《宅地法》。该法案向定居者开放了美国西部数百万英亩的土地。如果定居者耕种并改良了土地，
then after five years, they could file for a deed from the government and take legal ownership. At least legal in the eyes of the US government, not necessarily the native peoples who lived on the land for thousands of years. By the 1960s and 70s, the idea of urban homesteading had taken hold in cities. Local governments would offer cheap or free houses to low-income residents, provided they worked on the buildings and brought them up to code.
那么五年后，他们就可以向政府申请地契并获得法定所有权。至少在美利坚合众国政府眼里是合法的，但这不一定得到在这片土地上生活了数千年的原住民的认可。到了20世纪60和70年代，“城市宅地化”的概念在各大城市流行起来。地方政府向低收入居民提供便宜甚至免费的房屋，前提是他们必须对房屋进行修缮并使其符合建筑标准。
This was known as SWET equity. And some of the squatters in New York basically saw themselves as providing a kind of SWET equity, even if it wasn't under any officially sanctioned program. Many squatters may have lived outside the main stream, but in some ways they were tapping into mainstream American values that go way back in history. Values of self-sufficiency, entrepreneurialism, pulling yourself up by your bootstraps, individual responsibility, and so squatting fits in with that story too. But the city government didn't necessarily see it that way. And as time went on, the squaders' renegade methods would draw more critical attention in a city that was rapidly gentrifying.
这被称为“汗水股权”。纽约的一些占房者基本上认为自己是在提供某种“汗水股权”，尽管这不是在任何官方认可的项目下进行的。许多占房者可能生活在主流社会之外，但在某些方面，他们正在汲取可追溯到历史深处的美国主流价值观。诸如自给自足、企业家精神、自力更生、个人责任等价值观，因此占地居住也符合这个故事。但市政府并不一定这样认为。随着时间的推移，在一个迅速士绅化的城市里，占房者的叛逆方法将吸引更多的批评目光。
By the late 1980s, New York City had turned a corner and was gradually starting to come out of a long economic slump. People were moving back into the city, real estate prices were once again starting to climb, and the city was beginning to reinvest in neighborhoods it had long neglected. The issues of homelessness and housing on the Lower East Side were becoming more and more tense. Both squatters and homeless people felt like they had to fight to hang on to whatever spaces they had claimed. Do not try to kick the homeless out of the park because if you do, you got a war on your
到了20世纪80年代末，纽约市已经度过转折点，逐渐开始走出长期的经济低迷。人们重新搬回城市，房地产价格再次开始攀升，这座城市也开始对长期被忽视的街区进行重新投资。下东区的无家可归者和住房问题变得越来越紧张。占房者和无家可归者都觉得，他们必须奋力抗争，才能守住自己已经占据的任何空间。别想把无家可归的人赶出公园，因为如果你这么做，你就会给自己惹上一场战争，先生。
head, sir. A lot of the tension focused on Tompkin Square Park in the Lower East Side. The park was close to many of the squads and was the place where Spenulo had passed out his pro-squating pamphlets to homeless people. In the summer of 1988, the New York Parks Department implemented a 1am curfew at the park. They were hoping to reduce the number of people living and sleeping there. The curfew sparked protests which turned into riots. Many squatters were part of the altercations.
许多紧张局势都集中在下东区的汤普金斯广场公园。这个公园离许多占领区很近，也是斯佩努洛向无家可归者分发支持占房传单的地方。1988年夏天，纽约市公园管理局在公园实行了凌晨1点的宵禁。他们希望以此减少在那里生活和睡觉的人数。宵禁引发了抗议，最终演变成了骚乱。许多占房者都参与了这些冲突。
The rubber ball was thrown and hit part of the altercations. The rubber ball was thrown and hit one of the cops in the head. Photographers being pushed by police. The Tompkins Square Park riots were a turning point in the relationship between squatters and the city that brought a lot of the tensions around gentrification and displacement and class in the neighborhood to a head. More than ever, the city wanted the squatters out of the neighborhood.
橡胶球被扔出，击中了其中一名警察的头部。摄影师遭到警察的推搡。汤普金斯广场公园骚乱是占房者与市政府关系的一个转折点，它将围绕该社区士绅化、流离失所和阶层等诸多紧张局势推向了顶峰。比以往任何时候都更强烈的是，市政府希望将占房者赶出这个社区。
Local politicians and even some other affordable housing activists accused the squatters of not playing by the rules and of occupying buildings that were badly needed by other low-income residents who had deeper roots in the neighborhood. Hundreds and hundreds of our families are living double-dub, tripled up, and sometimes quadrupled up, and substandard housing while these yuppies squatters are stealing from the poor, leaving rent and tax free. This is an old interview from WNYC of a controversial city councilor named Antonio Pagan, who represented the Lower East Side. He was a housing developer, turned politician, and he emerged as a particularly fierce critic of the squatters. And they're standing in the way of the development of our community by the community. As criticism mounted, the city began working harder to evict the squatters.
地方政客甚至一些其他保障性住房活动人士指责占房者不守规矩，并指责他们占据了那些在社区扎根更深的低收入居民急需的房屋。我们成百上千的家庭挤在双倍、三倍甚至四倍拥挤的劣质住房里，而这些雅痞占房者却在窃取穷人的资源，不用交租金和税收。这是WNYC对一位名叫安东尼奥·帕甘的极具争议的市议员进行的旧采访，他代表下东区。他曾是一名房地产开发商，后转从政，并作为占房者极其坚定的批评者崭露头角。他们阻碍了我们社区由社区自己主导的发展。随着批评声不断高涨，市政府开始加大力度驱逐占房者。
And in response, the squatters began devising creative ways to resist eviction. Here's I didn't know fire, no con it, no nothing. That was one of the things that came out of that period was this real sort of siege mentality. And when the police did show up, the squatters had developed a plan for how to quickly mobilize the eviction watch. The eviction watch was an organization of squatters throughout the neighborhood. Here's Peter Spagnolo.
作为回应，占房者开始设计富有创造性的方式来抵抗驱逐。这里我不知道什么火灾，没有消防栓，什么都没有。那个时期涌现出的现象之一，就是这种真正类似于被围困的心态。当警察真的出现时，占房者已经制定好了一个计划，以便迅速动员“驱逐观察队”。“驱逐观察队”是由整个街区的占房者组成的一个组织。以下是彼得·斯潘尤洛的发言。
And having your name on this telephone tree meant that in the event you were called, you would come to a squat to do what you could to oppose an eviction. Squatters would physically block police from entering the building. They'd link arms and stand in front of the door. Sometimes they'd defend the buildings from the inside,
你的名字出现在这个电话联络网上，意味着一旦你接到电话，就会赶到某个占地处，尽你所能去反对驱逐。占房者会用身体阻挡警察进入大楼。他们会挽起手臂挡在门前。有时他们会从内部保卫大楼，
throwing paint and garbage down on the police or buckets of urine. Sometimes they'd hide inside, so that cops couldn't clear the building. They would have little secret compartments and hiding places to go and physically occupying the building was always the best strategy. The city was always very quick and eager
向警察投掷油漆和垃圾，或者泼尿桶。有时他们会躲在里面，这样警察就无法清空大楼。他们会设有小巧的秘密隔间和藏身之处供人躲藏，而实际占据大楼始终是最好的策略。市政府一向非常迅速且急切地
to demolish a squad. But they couldn't demolish a squad with people inside. So it would at least slow things down. The squatters weren't just fighting the city in the streets. They also began devising a legal strategy. We had developed, among ourselves, the idea of adverse possession. It's a legal theory. It's something you can use. Squatters love adverse possession law.
想要拆除一处占地建筑。但他们无法在里面有人时拆除建筑。所以这至少能拖延时间。占房者不只在街头与市政府对抗。他们还开始制定法律策略。我们在内部提出了“逆权占有”的想法。这是一个法律理论。这是一个你可以利用的东西。占房者非常热爱逆权占有法。
The details of the law vary state-by-state. In New York, it says that if you occupy a piece of property for 10 years and the legal owner doesn't force you out, you can claim the legal title. Adverse possession is an interesting law because it seems to destabilize some of the things that we say that we value about private property and ownership. Namely, that if you own a property, you have a right to it, and it's yours forever. Adverse possession means owners have certain responsibilities, too. If you abandon your property and leave it unused for long periods, you risk losing it.
该法律的细节因州而异。在纽约，法律规定如果你占有一处房产达10年之久，而法定所有人没有强行将你驱逐，你就可以声称获得法定所有权。逆权占有是一条有趣的法律，因为它似乎动摇了我们对私有财产和所有权所赋予的一些价值的认知。也就是说，如果你拥有某处房产，你就拥有对它的权利，并且它永远属于你。逆权占有意味着所有者也承担某些责任。如果你放弃房产并让其长期闲置，你就有可能失去它。
To successfully claim adverse possession, the squatters would need to meet a number of conditions, like proving they had lived in the buildings continuously, for example. Some of the squatters were wary about getting tangled up with the legal system, but others sought as their chance to gain ownership. They hired a lawyer and started putting together a case. The judge who heard their claim found they were likely to make a successful case against the city, and he granted them an injunction against eviction until the case was decided. But before the case could be settled in court and in spite of the injunction, the city
要成功主张逆权占有，占房者需要满足许多条件，例如证明他们一直在连续居住在这些建筑中。一些占房者对卷入法律体系心存戒备，但另一些人则将其视为获得所有权的机遇。他们聘请了律师，并开始着手准备诉讼。听取他们诉求的法官发现他们很有可能对市政府发起成功的诉讼，于是他下达了禁止驱逐令，直到案件宣判为止。然而，在案件在法庭得到解决之前，且不顾禁令的存在，市政府还是
evicted the residents of two of the buildings. City inspectors said that they were in danger of collapse. Here's Mera Neville, a spokeswoman for the housing department from an archival interview. The occupants of the five city-owned buildings on East 13th Street are squatters, and whether they've been there for five minutes, five years, or 15 years, the fact of the matter is they broke into vacant city-owned buildings that were sealed. These evictions provoked the biggest showdown yet between the city and the squatters, in May of 1995. Everybody was on edge and everybody was on the lookout. And I remember somebody called me one
驱逐了两栋建筑的居民。城市检查员称，这些建筑有倒塌的危险。这是住房部发言人梅拉·内维尔在一次资料采访中的发言。位于东13街的五栋属于市政府的建筑的占用者是占房者，无论他们在那里呆了五分钟、五年还是十五年，事实是他们私闯了被查封的市政府所有的空置建筑。这些驱逐行动引发了1995年5月市政府与占房者之间迄今为止最大的一次对峙。每个人都神经紧绷，每个人都在密切关注。我记得有一天晚上有人打电话给我，
night and they said, okay, this is like a hundred riot cops have arrived and they're like four blocks away. And then the number grew. They was sending in basically a small army. The police had brought a tank repurposed from the Korean War. Officers took up positions on the roofs of neighboring buildings. Meanwhile, squatters patrolled the neighborhood with walkie talkies, reporting on the growing numbers
他们说，好吧，大约有一百名防暴警察已经抵达，他们就在四个街区外。然后人数还在增加。他们基本上派了一支小军队进来。警察带来了一辆从朝鲜战争中改装而来的坦克。警官们在邻近建筑的屋顶上占据了有利地形。与此同时，占房者拿着对讲机在街区巡逻，通报着不断增多的警察人数。
of police. They welded bicycle frames to their fire escapes, so it would be impossible for police or firefighters to climb them. They packed their staircases with rubble to make them impossible. They poured tar on the street so police would have to march through it on their way to the buildings. And again, creative responses, you know, chaining stuff to the building. You use your piss bucket and nobody's gonna try and come to you know, it's like, it's vile, but it's like, hey, you got guns, we got piss buckets.
他们将自行车架焊接在逃生梯上，这样警察或消防员就根本无法攀爬。他们在楼梯上堆满瓦砾，使其无法通行。他们在街上倒满柏油，这样警察在前往建筑物的路上就不得不蹚着柏油前进。再次展现了极具创造力的应对措施，比如把东西锁在建筑物上。你用上你的尿桶，就没人会试图靠近你，你知道的，这太恶心了，但感觉就像是，嘿，你们有枪，我们有尿桶。
The police presence went on for months. They sealed off the ends of the block and required people to show ID before they'd let them through. Still, the squatters wouldn't leave. And I think that that expense and inconvenience and embarrassment is part of what led the city to eventually decide that this wasn't the way to go and they were going to have to find some other way to deal with the squatters that were left in the buildings. Rudy Giuliani was the mayor of the city at the time and he was a vocal critic of the
警察的这种驻守持续了数月。他们封锁了街区两端，要求人们出示身份证件才让通过。尽管如此，占房者还是不肯离开。我认为正是这种开销、不便和尴尬，最终促使市政府决定此路不通，他们必须找到其他办法来处理留在楼里的占房者。时任纽约市长鲁迪·朱利安尼是
squatters, but astonishingly in 1999, a secret negotiation between the city and the squatters started to unfold. They began to discuss what had once seemed impossible. Legalization. I remember being surprised by the fact that we were going to have this discussion. And it was Giuliani administration, which just made it weirder and weirder, and it was just hard to fathom. A new plan started to develop, separate from the adverse possession case. The city would sell the squatters buildings to a third party, a nonprofit organization called U-Hab, the urban homesteading
占房者的直言不讳的批评者，但令人惊讶的是，在1999年，市政府与占房者之间展开了一场秘密谈判。他们开始讨论曾经看似不可能的事情——合法化。我记得当时很惊讶我们居然要讨论这个。而且这还是朱利安尼政府，这让事情变得越来越诡异，简直让人捉摸不透。一项独立于逆权占有案的新计划开始酝酿。市政府将把占房者的建筑出售给第三方，即一个名为U-Hab（城市宅地化协助委员会）的非营利组织。
assistance board. Since the 1970s, U-Hab had been helping low-income New Yorkers gain ownership of distressed properties. U-Hab would then turn the buildings over to the squatters and help them get loans so they could bring the buildings up to code. After years of negotiation, the deal went through. In 2002, the city sold 11 buildings to you have for $1 each. And you have began working with the squatters to turn their buildings from squats into legal, cooperatively owned apartments. The process wasn't easy, and it raised some hard questions in from squats into legal, cooperatively-owned apartments. The process wasn't easy, and it raised some hard questions in the squats.
自20世纪70年代以来，U-Hab一直帮助低收入的纽约人获得陷入困境的房产的所有权。然后，U-Hab会将这些建筑移交给占房者，并帮助他们获得贷款，以便他们能够使这些建筑符合建筑规范。经过多年的谈判，这笔交易终于达成。2002年，市政府以每栋1美元的价格将11栋建筑卖给了U-Hab。U-Hab开始与占房者合作，将他们的建筑从占地住所改造成合法的、合作拥有的公寓。这个过程并不容易，并在占地建筑内部引发了一些棘手的问题。从占地住所改造成合法的、合作拥有的公寓。这个过程并不容易，并在占地建筑内部引发了一些棘手的问题。
For one thing, there was the issue of resale. Many squatters were committed to keeping the buildings affordable. They wanted to cap the resale price on each apartment, so that people couldn't flip their units for massive sums of money. But there were others who felt like they'd invested so much time and energy into the buildings that they wanted to be able to cash out. There was a bunch of people who, you know, basically the line was, well, if we're not going to be anarchists anymore, we might as well be capitalists. It was like, a rock? Yeah, what?
首先是转售问题。许多占房者致力于保持房屋的可负担性。他们希望对每套公寓的转售价格设定上限，这样人们就不能通过转手他们的单元来获取巨额利润。但也有另一些人觉得，他们为这些建筑投入了如此多的时间和精力，以至于他们希望能把钱套现。有一群人，你知道的，他们的底线基本上就是，好吧，既然我们不再做无政府主义者了，那我们干脆做资本主义者得了。这就像是一块石头？对，怎么了？
As the squatters rehabbed the buildings and brought them up to code, some of the more unique and hand-built elements of people's apartments had to go. Some of the buildings became less wild, more uniform. Fewer handmade mosaics, more boring drywall. A few of the buildings haven't managed to get through the legalization process, even 15 years later. There have been hard trade-offs. Some squatters didn't want to take on debt for the building renovations, and they've moved out. But for many, like Maggie Riggley, the legalization has been a victory for affordable housing,
随着占房者修缮建筑并使其达到规范要求，人们公寓中一些更具特色和手工建造的元素不得不被拆除。其中一些建筑变得不那么狂野，更加整齐划一。手工艺马赛克少了，枯燥的干墙多了。即便在15年后的今天，仍有一些建筑未能完成合法化进程。这里面有艰难的权衡。有些占房者不想为建筑翻新背负债务，于是搬走了。但对许多人来说，比如玛姬·里格利，合法化是保障性住房的一次胜利，
in one of the most expensive cities in the country. And it's offered a kind of stability at the end of nearly two decades of drama. We were accused of everything, you know, speculation, trying to steal these buildings of profiteering. And that's the beautiful thing about where we are today. It will always, these buildings will always be affordable housing. Maggie's building was the first
在这个国家物价最高的城市之一。它在经历了近二十年的戏剧性风波后，提供了一种稳定性。我们被指控了一切，你知道的，投机、试图窃取这些建筑、谋取暴利。这就是我们今天所处状态的美妙之处。这些建筑将永远是经济适用房，永远都是。玛姬的建筑是第一栋
to finish the legalization process in 2009. It's still full of artists and activists. Many of the people who live there have been there for years and years. People are starting to have kids and start families. There's not that sense of constant threat. The fear that police might come by and break up all their windows.
在2009年完成合法化进程的建筑。这里依然住满了艺术家和活动人士。许多住在这里的人已经住了好几年。人们开始生孩子，组建家庭。那种持续受威胁的感觉已经消失了。那种警察可能会随时上门砸碎他们所有窗户的恐惧不复存在了。
Maggie's not a squad or any more. She's something else. I am Mahal Mah, and it's incredible. And, you know, as long as we keep our act together, then nobody can put us out, you know. And that's it. We got it, you know. It's our building. It's ours to lose. This week's episode is part of a special radio-topia-wide project welcoming a new radio-topia podcast to the family.
玛姬不再是一个占房者了。她是别的什么人。我是玛哈尔·玛哈，这太不可思议了。而且，你知道的，只要我们循规蹈矩，那么没有人能把我们赶出去，你知道的。就是这样。我们拿到了，你知道的。这是我们的建筑。是我们自己的，绝不能失去。本周的节目是一个名为Radio-topia的特别全网项目的一部分，旨在欢迎一个新的Radio-topia播客加入这个大家庭。
Ear Hustle, which is coming soon, shares true stories of life in San Quentin State, present, told directly by and from the men living there. The show won radio-topia's podcast contest last year, beginning out 1536 other entries from around the world. In support of your hustle, all radio topia shows are releasing an episode in response to the theme, Do-ing Time. In our case, we took it as Do-ing Time in a place to make a claim of ownership. Be sure to subscribe to all the radio topia shows as they interpret Do-ing Time.
即将开播的《Ear Hustle》将分享圣昆廷州立监狱真实的生活故事，由住在那里的人们直接讲述。该节目赢得了去年Radio-topia的播客比赛，在来自世界各地的1536个参赛作品中脱颖而出。为了支持《Ear Hustle》，所有Radio-topia的节目都将围绕“服刑”这一主题发布一期节目。就我们而言，我们将之理解为在一个地方“服刑”以宣示所有权。请务必订阅所有Radio-topia节目，看看他们如何诠释“服刑”。
I'm really excited to hear how all the other shows handle it, and stay tuned through the credits of this show to hear a special, extra long, sneak preview of your hustle. 99% of the show was produced this week by Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Sheree Husef. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the production staff includes Avery Trollflin, Emmett Fitzgerald, and me Roman Mars. Terry Maza is the office manager and Sean Rial composed original music for this episode,
我非常期待听到所有其他节目将如何处理这个主题，并通过本节目的片尾制作人员名单收听《Ear Hustle》的特别超长超前预览。本周的节目由德莱尼·霍尔制作，混音和技术制作由谢里·胡塞夫负责。凯蒂·明格是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド是数字总监。其余制作人员包括埃弗里·特罗夫林、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。特里·马扎是办公室经理，肖恩·里亚尔为本期节目创作了原创音乐，
alongside music by Melodium and Okakumi. Thank you to Dr. Amy Starchesky, who provided us with oral history interviews with the lower east side squatters. This episode is based on her book called R's to Lose, when squatters became homeowners in New York City. Thanks also to Alex Vasudeván, author of The Autonomous City. Thanks to Paul Dureenzo for his tape of the Topkin Square Park riots recorded for WBAI and WNYC for additional archival tape. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
此外还有梅洛迪姆和奥卡库姆的音乐。感谢艾米·斯塔chesky博士，她为我们提供了关于下东区占房者的口述历史采访。本期节目改编自她的同名书作《失去的权利：当占房者成为纽约市的业主》。同时感谢《自主城市》一书的作者亚历克斯·瓦苏德万。感谢保罗·杜伦佐为我们提供WBAI录制的汤普金斯广场公园骚乱磁带，并感谢WNYC提供的额外历史资料磁带。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的项目，在美丽加州奥克兰市中心的“无线电街”制作。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。
You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too, which are always welcome at our place at 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Twitter上@罗曼·马尔斯，或在99pi.org上@本节目。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上活跃，随时欢迎大家访问我们的网站99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio-topia。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。